en el vídeo anterior vimos este circuito
con una entrada tipo escalón que va de 0
a bs con esta fuente que hace un cambio
brusco cuando t es igual a 0 y usando
nuestra intuición deducimos cómo luciría
este voltaje de aquí vedete en este
vídeo vamos a desarrollar una expresión
precisa de lo que ocurre aquí con el
voltaje a través de este capacitor
nuevamente recordamos que este es un
circuito muy común pues hay miles de
millones de estos en todas y cada una de
las computadoras por lo que vale la pena
estudiar su comportamiento y
comprenderlo a detalle debido a que esta
es una función del tiempo vamos a tener
que ocupar ciertas técnicas de cálculo
para encontrar esto apropiadamente así
que aquí necesitaremos usar nuestras
habilidades con el cálculo también vamos
a suponer que ya vieron el vídeo sobre
la respuesta natural del circuito rc en
donde encontramos justamente cuál es la
respuesta natural de este circuito
la que ocurre cuando no tenemos un
voltaje aquí la respuesta natural es b
igual a de 0 por ala menos t entre el
reporte y tenemos un vídeo y un artículo
en khan academy sobre esta respuesta
natural que los invito a que vean vamos
a analizar esto formalmente y lo primero
que debemos hacer es poner etiquetas a
las cantidades que nos interesan aquí
tenemos la corriente y al voltaje de
aquí le llamamos br aquí usamos
minúsculas cuando la cantidad cambia con
el tiempo y cuando usamos mayúsculas
significa que estos valores no van a
cambiar con el tiempo cuando analizamos
el circuito es bueno que veamos cuáles
son las ecuaciones de los componentes de
este circuito para esta resistencia ya
sabemos que br es igual a por r otra
forma de escribirlo es y igual
r / r y la expresión para el capacitor
es su ecuación y ve que es y igual hace
debe de t que significa que la pendiente
del voltaje o la tasa de cambio del
voltaje multiplicada por c es igual a la
corriente en este circuito sólo
tendremos una corriente por lo que está
in de a quien es igual a la idea acá y
es bueno que conozcamos esta relación
también tenemos dos variables clave del
capacitor y verde la resistencia vamos a
ver si podemos escribir a ver en
términos de ve y viendo este circuito
nos damos cuenta de que esto apunta en
esta dirección
aquí tenemos ads y en este punto de aquí
tenemos a de c por lo que escribimos br
igual a bs menos veces
ahora vamos a igualar estas is y al
mismo tiempo vamos a sustituir la
expresión de de s - veces en lugar de
ver aquí arriba
escribimos se debe de t igual a 1 entre
r por de r&b es bs menos ve aquí
realmente es ver vamos a quitar la sede
aquí distribuimos 1 entre r y nos queda
se debe
dt es igual a 1 entre r por bs menos 1
entre reporte
seguimos se debe de t más 1 entre r por
ver es igual a bs entre r esta es
nuestra ecuación diferencial y es
diferencial porque tiene una derivada en
particular es una ecuación diferencial
ordinaria no homogénea
es ordinaria porque tiene una primera
derivada las primeras derivadas tienen
un 1 como exponente aquí es diferenciar
porque tiene una derivada y es no
homogénea porque este lado de aquí no
tiene un ave o una derivada de b así que
esta ecuación es no homogénea cuando
hicimos el análisis de la respuesta
natural esto era igual a 0 y por eso
pudimos resolverlo rápidamente por lo
que aquí vamos a desarrollar una nueva
estrategia para resolver este tipo de
ecuaciones y de o no homogéneas esta
ecuación no es tan sencilla de resolver
porque no es igual a cero este lado de
la ecuación representa a la función
forzada que es lo que está alimentando
al circuito con la fuente de voltaje
escalón este lado de aquí lo vamos a
asociar con las condiciones iniciales
que tiene el capacitor por lo que aquí
están sucediendo dos cosas diferentes y
esto complica un poco más el encontrar
la solución qué estrategia vamos a usar
bueno nuestra estrategia va a ser
dividir el problema en dos y es lo que
siempre hacen los ingenieros cuando se
encuentran con algo complicado lo
dividen en problemas más pequeños por lo
que nuestra estrategia será encontrar la
respuesta natural más y vamos a
encontrar algo llamado la respuesta
forzada los vamos a sumar y nos dará lo
que llamamos la respuesta total que es
lo que realmente hace el circuito
tenemos dos términos nuevos la respuesta
forzada y la respuesta total ya vimos
que la respuesta natural es el
comportamiento del circuito cuando nada
lo está forzando solamente
proporcionamos algo de energía inicial
algo de carga y dejamos que el circuito
llegue a donde tiene que llegar esta es
la respuesta natural
la respuesta forzada es lo que en el
circuito se ve obligado a hacer por la
fuente de entrada
tomamos ambas cosas las sumamos y esto
nos dará el comportamiento total del
circuito esta es otra buena aplicación
de la superposición tomamos dos cosas
que hace el circuito las analizamos por
separado la sumamos la super ponemos y
tenemos la respuesta total vamos a hacer
esto primero analizando la respuesta
natural viendo sus condiciones iniciales
que es la carga en el capacitor la carga
inicial q y el voltaje de 0 después
veremos las entradas que son 0 para la
respuesta natural estas son las
condiciones para la respuesta natural
ahora analicemos la respuesta forzada
sus condiciones iniciales son 0 para
simplificar el circuito y usamos las
entradas que aplican en este caso
y obtenemos la respuesta total sumando
ambas así que para la respuesta total
tendremos las condiciones iniciales cv y
de 0 y también tenemos de ese todo junto
esta es nuestra estrategia al
descomponer esto en dos problemas más
sencillos hacemos que sea más simple el
resolver esta ecuación diferencial en
lugar de resolver la completa de una
sola vez nos detendremos aquí y en el
siguiente vídeo continuaremos con la
estrategia de combinar la respuesta
natural con la respuesta forzada